Dear kitten, you see how some of the humans are wearing traditional robes of some sort.
I can't tell what they signify in terms of status.
But I am pretty sure that one is the idiot.
The humans seem to have some sort of a ritual.
When the light box suddenly gets loud,...
...all of the humans try to be the first to jump up and shout louder than anyone else.
The person who gets up the fastest is the winner...
...and gets to hit people with his paws.
The slowest people to get up are then taunted for their inadequacies...
...and they become very sad.
It's actually quite a cruel game.
But it's a cruel world.
If you can find someone who sneezes every time you get near them, get near them.
And when it's time, you just walk right in front of the light box...
...and sit down like you don't know what's going on...
...and then 3, 2, 1, that's right.
Kitty get an airplane ride.
A little private jet to the only prize worth competing for.
A can of moist, delicious wet food.
And touchdown.
Works every time.
Kitty gets what he wants.